This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, bachelor
of science in plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational
purposes. says only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
Hello everybody. Let's go ahead and open
up that waiting room. Thank you so much
for your patience. As you know,
everything's going great until it
doesn't. Well, it is on with the show
here on Daily with Doc. My name is Becca
Tukes and as a certified holistic health
coach and a certified naturopathic
practitioner and the host and producer
of this show, it is my honor and
privilege to do whatever it takes to
keep the show going. And today's
conversation may challenge something
that you thought you already knew.
We are thrilled to welcome back to the
show Dr. Judy Reynolds for a fascinating
discussion titled niacin. What's in a
name? Have you ever heard the word
nicotinic acid? Nyinomide
and immediately thought, wait, does that
have something to do with nicotine? You
are not alone. Well, today we're going
to be diving into one of the most
misunderstood nutrients in the vitamin
world and uncover the truth about
vitamin B3. Despite the name nicotinic
acid and nic
nioinomide,
an immediate thought,
sorry, another one of those technical
things where everything just went away.
So, we're just going to keep on rolling.
Folks, if you are invited to this
program by somebody specific, make sure
that you get back with them as they
cared enough about you to share this
program. We want to make sure that you
get back with them with any questions
that you may have as they may be one of
the amazing certified holistic health
coaches that this program is a resource
for. And if you found us on your own and
you'd like to get in touch with a
certified holistic health coach, you may
join us
or talk to one of our great certified
holistic health coaches um that's
associated with the show by calling
855-9493377.
Well, today we're going to be exploring
vitamin B3, the given names, and the
difference between nyin niacin and
niainamide
and why neither form is nicotine. So, I
am super excited, but we're also going
to be talking about the health benefits
and why they are so important. I am
super excited to have with us Dr. Judy
Reynolds. Dr. Judy, welcome. Thank you
so much. I know you put so much work
into these and want everything to be
just perfect and you do such a fantastic
job. We always have people wanting to
know when you're coming back. So, let's
go ahead and share a little bit um first
about you. So, Dr. Judy is a doctor in
uh she has a doctorate in nutrition
and studied primarily in horse. But
folks, when you're studying nutrition,
whether it's horse or humans, it's the
same classes, right? Pretty much.
Yeah. And then yes,
>> you were very instrument, you've been so
instrumental in the horse world and in
the formulation of horse feeds. And that
study has been able to allow you to just
pull right on over into the human world
and keep us a breast of what our bodies
really need. So, Dr. Judy, we greatly
appreciate that you are bringing this
topic because I know it is all over the
internet
>> and you're going to be um possibly
exposing some misconceptions and
misunderstandings.
>> Well, and and that's why this topic I
think I mean it's been important for a
long time and I follow a lot of
different people in the health space.
I also follow a lot of people in other
different spaces. I mean, you probably,
you know, I follow what's going on with
the aliens. I follow what's going on
with just about everything as far as
what people are thinking. But this one
is just a, it seems to have grown so
big, so exponentially.
And, you know, it can be a possible bad
consequence. And so I've actually tried
to talk to people that, you know, that
are kind of working them with that
theory and I can't get them to get back
to me. I've tried for actually two
years.
And that's ridiculous because, okay, one
of my main philosophies is you don't
interrupt a speaker on their topic on
their space. You talk to them behind the
scenes. You get with them. You have a
discussion. I'm not going to go out and
start fighting wars and battles and and
critiquing other people on their
presentations. Right. So, I won't do
that.
>> That's a professional common sense,
right?
>> Well, exactly. And so, that's what ends
up happening is that then if there's no
way to contact a lot of people that are
out there, they may say, "Oh, okay. You
know, here's my email address and here's
my this and that." But you can't reach
them. And so, you know, it just becomes
one of those things. Well, it it got to
the point where I I mean, I've heard
people in so many different spaces that
really don't have that much to do with
nutrition or anything, talking about
using nicotine
for
viruses, specifically spike protein and
things like that. And I know the theory.
I know why it happened. I know what the
whole thing is, but the issue is that
it's not when things that are called
nicotinic acid
and nicotenomide are niacin. They're the
B vitamin, the essential B vitamin nin.
And also the neurotransmitters in both
our muscles and our nerves are called
nicotinic acetylcholine re receptors or
NAD for the electron transport system is
nicotinic
um adinine duc nucleotide. All these
things are called nicotine but they're
not nicotine the molecule they're
niacin. And so it, you know, that one
little mistake and it's just because if
you think about it, when when people
find when people discover something,
they name it. A lot of times they'll
name it if it's a if it's a scientist,
they'll name it after themselves. You
know, the Krebs cycle was Dr. Krebs
figured out the intermediary metabolism
cycle for those biochemistry nerds out
there. So, and and with the like the
black gene lies that we've talked about
in the past, Dr. Wallik's book where um
cickle cell anemia
is called in the black population is
calledthalismia
in the white population because it was
discovered in two places by two people
and they each named it but it's the same
thing. So if you're trying to call it
genetic and then you blame it on a
population because of their different
genetics but then it's also happening in
another population, you've made a
mistake. And so anyway, mistakes happen
all the time. Um, I have to I have to
comment that when I go back and listen
to these presentations, I kind of get in
the zone and I'm doing my thing and I go
back and listen to them and every once
in a while I'm thinking I know what I
was going to say and something else just
came out of my mouth and I'm just like,
what? Why did I say that? So, I know
people make mistakes and I'm not trying
to be a perfectionist or anything like
that, but I think this got to the point
where people I never would have expected
are talking about getting these patches
and stuff. So, anyway,
um let's go ahead and see how the slides
work. Got my fingers crossed here
because I've had lots of slide issues
today. But, let's go ahead and see how
see how we're doing. Um, I got to bring
them up.
And there they are. And we're just going
to ignore this again.
That was the least of my worries today.
So,
okay.
What is nasin? First of all, we got to
remember that we've got to meet all of
our essential needs. Um, I spent the
last two days doing an online version of
the Ecoin Science Society. It was really
fun. Got to see uh a lot of colleagues,
but I had to laugh because I think four
out of the five or six pres presenters
are all retiring right now and they're
all talking about their 20 and 30 years
of being there and I'm thinking, wow, I
was in that same group, you know? I
mean, I retired about 14 years ago, but
crazy. I mean, that they're all
retiring. But it's you know what what
I'll be able to talk about this again
soon again soon. That's what I'm
planning to do is do a summary or some
thoughts. Um they were talking about a
bunch of different things that are are
kind of um relating to what we do in
nutrition. But for the most part again
they're horse specialists. So them doing
other them doing things that relate to
nutrition for people. It's nice to see
that that's happening and nice to see
that, you know, people are still doing
that kind of thing. But anyway, okay,
we've got to meet all the essential
needs and and that's what happened at
that conference is they were very very
focused on one nutrient and we cannot do
that. Even though we're going to talk
about nasin and all this kind of stuff,
we've got to really understand that I
call it fractionated nutrition.
So before we can do anything with niain,
we have to make sure that the the
essential needs of all the nutrients are
met. And that's basically what what what
Dr. Wallock does too is he's just, you
know, make sure that that all the needs
are met. So start there. Metabolism is
millions of reactions, hopefully faster
because of catalysts and because of the
correct nutrients. But we've got to have
all those needs met. So the 90 have to
be there. Let's just start there. Um,
and this is just a quote from Dr.
Wallock. The methodical science-based
approach to veterinary and I added and
animal science formulation of animal
rations decreased disease and maximized
fertility, longevity, and production
such as with eggs, meat, and milk in
animals versus humans. We have
insurance.
So unfortunately that's what gets
focused on and we don't realize we're
paying all this money for our healthcare
and you know that's that's a a great
topic if you want to go look that up
within doc's books.
Okay. And again I've got to do this one
because
every nutrient if you don't get enough
you die. If you get too much you die.
And we have this thing we call the NRC,
the National Research Council, and this
is the horse nutrient requirements, but
then we have the same ones for people.
And we've got to make sure that we're
meeting these needs.
And here's just a a quick one. The RDA
is not enough. Again, we have to have
all 90 essential nutrients. This is uh
Roger Williams from he he lived from
1893 to 1988 and he wrote the
biochemical individuality book
and he said nutrition is for real
people. Statistical humans are of little
interest. So um nutrition is always
improvable is basically the point there.
We can always do a better job.
Okay, back to our vitamins.
Classification of vitamins. Remember, we
have two main compartments within the
body. And the first one is the water
compartments. That's the inside of the
cells, the blood, the extracellular
fluids and all those things. And then we
have the fat soluble and that is the
membranes around each cell. We have a
fatty membrane. We also have the all the
nerves in the body, the brain, central
nervous system, all of those things. So
we are talking about the water soluble
vitamins, the ones that are in that
those watery compartments.
And what what are these like?
Basically, all organisms need water
soluble vitamins. They're needed by
simple and complex organizations. They
contain carbon, hydrogen, oxygen, and
nitrogen.
Some contain minerals, for example,
cobalt and sulfur. And they're absorbed
through the portal vein, which means
they just go from the digestive system
right to the liver.
And the big thing about water-soluble
vitamins is they're it's very tough to
have them be toxic. So, that's a good
thing. They're needed every day. they
are um expelled in urine, the parts that
aren't needed or the amount that aren't
needed, but you're not likely to have a
toxicity from taking too many.
Okay, I just mentioned most of those. We
don't have a way to store them. So,
they're excreted every day.
And another thing is they don't they
usually come and go in the same shape
they started in. Whereas our fats and
sugars and all those things, we break
them down into smaller molecules.
Okay, here's where we start talking
about vitamin
B3 or niacin.
And this is just to show you we knew
about problems with vitamins all the way
back in 2697 BC. The deficiency of of
thamin was understood in China and they
named it Barry Berry. And then scurvy
1500 BC 1920 pelagra which is the nasin
deficiency disease. And here you can see
it was isolated from NADP
which is called nicotine adinine
um ducleic d
nucleotide phosphate. However that
nicotine is niacin.
Okay. So again it's just terminology.
Okay. And here we go into the
controversial part here. The names for
nascin.
Nicotenomide was confused with nicotine
in tobacco.
Nicotinomide
was renamed because of this confusion
was renamed by the scholars that worked
a lot on B vitamins and health and they
said this is so confusing let's just
rename it so they named it niainomide
instead and nicotinic acid named it
niacinic acid. So you will see those in
the literature in the newer places you
might see the actual niocinic acid. So
nicotine adinine dneleotide
again got changed to nyinomide NADP got
changed and here we're when we talk
about our receptors
you have nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors and they are niacinic really
not nicotinic.
Okay, so here's the series of events.
Those receptors are found in a lot of
places in the body
and um it's not that important exactly
which ones. I I didn't go into that much
detail there, but basically these
receptors about half of them use niacin
and the other half use other things. So
I'm not going to worry about those. They
affect receptors in the brain and
nervous system mostly. And here's the
theory that venoms were used to create
the spike protein.
And
we are we already know this is just one
example I found from another source.
Spider venom has been shown to disrupt
those niacinic acetylcholine receptors
causing a lack of function. So what
happens is the venom goes in and it you
do not get the neur normal transmission
of the nerve from
the neuron before the syninnapse.
basically a neuron. You have a neuron, a
preinaptic neuron. Then you have a
syninnapse which is a space, an open
space, and then you have a post synaptic
neuron. And in that process, little
vesicles of neurotransmitters
come out from the first one and have to
bridge that gap and go to the second
one. And what the venom does, it can do
different things, but it can either
prevent
the neurotransmitter from going where
it's supposed to go at all. It just
doesn't go out. It might go out too
fast.
Or you might not be able to get rid of
it soon enough because each time uh you
have a syninnapse, each time you have a
nerve going across it, it has to fire
and do its job and then stop.
So you can have, you know, a lot of
different problems.
But what happened is
you you you were seeing the effects of
venom.
That was that was what people were
reading as respiratory dysfunction. They
were reading it as a problem with your
respiratory system, with breathing.
But what venoms do is they stop nerve
transmission and they stop muscle
contraction.
And so the theory here is that the
diaphragm
is a muscle that has to open and
basically that muscle has to open up the
chest cavity so the lungs will inflate.
The lungs are not muscular. They're just
tiny little air sacks and they don't
inflate unless the muscles of the
diaphragm and the chest open up. And so
basically what happened is venoms and we
know snake venom we know exactly what to
do with all different kinds of snakes.
We have to have an antivenenom.
So, so this is what is happening is that
those venoms
were causing symptoms of
these these diseases that were you know
labeled viral lately and because of that
treatments were incorrect.
Okay. And then this has been going on
for six years. So it's been a long time.
And some people again they looked at
nicotine
looked at called them nicotinic
receptors and thought well what if maybe
if nicotine would work. So what they did
is they started experimenting with
nicotine and it seems that that has
helped.
So what it's looking like is those
receptors have the highest affinity
for
the spike protein,
but then if nicotine comes in and binds,
then there's no place for the spike to
bind.
And then also, they haven't done
experiments on this that I know of, but
nascin actually would do that and do it
better. And the difference I'll show you
the molecules in a minute. The
difference is that if if nicotine binds
there it can stop the binding of the
spike protein but it does not give the
benefits of niacin the B vitamin which
are necessary all over the body. So
again,
you know, there are anecdotal
results of nicotine maybe helping
with long COVID, things like that. But
the point here is it's the wrong
substance and they're very similar. It's
the wrong substance. So if you use the
niacin instead, you would get the
benefits of niacin and not any potential
problems with nicotine. And I am going
to make a caution here because because
of this research and because of all the
things that that have been brought out
recently,
it looks like
um and I and I did find one reference,
maybe two. I think I found two um that
said we don't know how much nicotine and
niacin can be changed within the body.
So it's possible that using nicotine the
body might change it back to niacin.
Again this is a new a new thing to be
studying. So we don't know but there are
you know there is also an issue um
nicotine itself when we look at nicotine
and here you know we're going to another
topic here but we look at nicotine
itself it is found in tobacco it's also
found in a lot of other vegetables like
celery and tomatoes and things like that
in small amounts
and so another new theory that we all
need to consider is that it's not the
nicotine
in this in the tobacco
It was all the chemicals.
And I did go through and look at some
tobacco literature and it sounds like
there may have been 400 different
chemicals in cigarettes. There's a whole
history of cigarettes and you know them
pretending they were useful, pretending
they were good, and then we find out
they cause all kinds of bad things,
which is pretty simple to look that up.
Okay, so we're in the rabbit hole. Okay,
so this book
was I think it's 2026. Um, but these
three people
unfortunately have all passed away.
Um, Dr. Hoffer
was the original person studying nasin
for
psychiatric issues. And this is a huge
thing because a lot of this was just
under, you know, it it was just not
accepted.
And yet we've recently found that the
drugs they've used used for psychiatric
problems for children, for you know,
adults, all kinds of of psychiatric
issues, the drugs they've used for them,
they're now finding don't work and never
did work. And yet there's this huge body
of research of the benefits of nascin
for psychiatric issues. And so all this
is starting to come out. But this book
um Dr. Saul is a PhD and he taught
nutrition and I've followed him. I've
got everything that he put out over over
years. He's written probably 15 books at
least all relating to vitamins. There
was a there was a movie called That
Vitamin Movie and you can purchase it. I
hope you can still purchase his stuff
online um because he just passed away
recently. Um
but and then there's another book
called um
oh I'm going to forget now. It's it was
all he and his people go back to the
orthome orthomolecular
medicine group which goes back to Linus
Pauling.
So you can find that kind of stuff
there. But Dr. Saul again lots of books
teaching and I remember in one of the
movies um
it might have been that vitamin movie I
think it was he visited a penitentiary
and he convinced them to give a basic
vitamin mineral supplement
to the people there
and he said it was amazing how much
better the people got along ong how how
good they were mentally compared to what
they had been before.
And logically doing a much better
vitamin nutrition program would in my
opinion certainly and everything I say
on this program is my opinion obviously
um
would would be so much better for people
who are who are incarcerated and people
who have mental illness. So hopefully
we're going to, you know, go past this
corner and start realizing that there
are there is help out there. Um the
other two were actual um Dr. Hoffer and
Dr. Foster were researchers that did
decades of research and Dr. Saul was the
editor of the orthomolecular news for
years and he just helped bring all this
stuff together so we would get this
information. So this book's amazing. Um,
I did this so that you can if you can,
you know, stop it and go back and look.
He covers so many amazing topics here.
This is the contents of the book and you
can see that he talks about um I'm going
to I've got the book in front of me here
so I might I can see it better. I can't
read it on the screen
hopefully. Okay. So, a couple of the
main things just just to point something
out. Um, nascin therapy,
how to take it, this, it's safety,
um, arthritis,
children's learning and behavioral
disorders, mental illness,
cardiovascular disease, and here's a
list mostly on that second um, page
there, but aging, allergies, alcoholism,
and this is huge.
Nascin is big um because alcoholics need
niacin and niacin helps alcoholics.
Alzheimer's disease and then we have
anxiety, cancer, cataracts, chalera,
diarrhea, detoxification,
erectile dysfunction,
um fatigue, heartnips disease,
Huntington's disease, migraine
headaches, multiple sclerosis, nefritis,
which is problems, uh in inflammation in
the kidney, obesity, Parkinson's,
um post-traumatic stress disorder,
just unbelievable trigeminal neural
algia and Becca, you probably know what
that is since you co-op offered authored
a book about it. Okay. And then he talks
about COVID for NASA
or I'm sorry, Nasin for COVID. Um,
and then he's got appendices that are
the writings of a bunch of different
people that were in other books. So, an
amazing book. I hope it doesn't go out
of publication.
Um,
I really hope it doesn't, but we'll have
to see. His daughter also wrote a bunch
of books with him and she's hopefully
carrying on. So, you know, fingers
crossed on that. Okay, I have to show
you these molecules and hopefully you
can see I drew the ones
um rather than, you know, it's amazing.
You can't find information about
nicotine or nas and nascin together and
because you have to go looking through
the tobacco stuff and they don't do
hardly anything with diagrams. But for
the the nutritionists, they don't even
talk about nicotine. You have to go
looking for it. But anyway, pretty
simple. Okay, these are carbon. This is
a carbon ring with a nasin at the bottom
and nascin molecule. It's just got a C
with an O. That's called a CO group.
It's pretty common. Nicotinic acid. All
it is is you have a CO NH2
in instead of the CO.
That's the only difference in those two
molecules. Okay? And they have the same
function. So, wherever something
attaches to the molecule, it's got to be
within
I don't know. You're not seeing my
pointer, which that thing takes a nap a
lot. There it is. Um, so this part is
what's different right here. But then
when you see nicotine, this ring is
identical.
These three are identical. But the
nicotine has this whole other part.
So if this part is attaching to the
receptor any all three of them can
attach to those acetylcholine receptors.
But when this part, this extra part from
the nicotine is also there, you're
losing the function of this being able
to attach and do other things. So this
is basically the structural
component.
Okay. From here on
is just talking about the discovery B
vitamins, some of the things I've
covered in other talks. But I would like
to see if people have questions now
about this.
And I think that might be the best thing
is to is to do that and I can go back
and do that and then um if people want
we can go on and do more. We'll see how
our time is here.
>> No, Dr. Judy, I have the first question.
>> Okay. You had mentioned a virus and
nascin being beneficial for that virus.
Would it be beneficial for other viruses
as well?
That is a great question
and the reason this particular virus was
brought up was because of what they call
that spike protein. It's a specific
>> part of that virus
whether or not it does all viruses. I
know vitamin C does.
Um I know that vitamin D when the whole
this whole thing started happening. Um,
there was there was an article that came
out that I sent around to all my friends
and everybody from Orthomolecular
News and it showed that if you had
enough vitamin D, you did not get that
virus. Period. You didn't get it.
So, my thought is chances are yes.
Again, we got to have all 90. They all
have to work together.
The most important ones that we have to
have every day are the B and B vitamins
and vitamin C.
And you know
how it's hard to separate what works and
what doesn't work. But we got to have
all the essentials. And then the ones we
are more likely to run out of when we're
sick because we can't make them
ourselves are these B vitamins and
vitamin C.
>> Okay.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much. somebody had
um seen today's title and said, "Hey,
I'm not going to be able to be there,
but I'm curious to know if it's
beneficial for more than just
this the sea virus." Anyways,
>> yeah.
>> Um, anybody else have any questions? If
do please raise your hand and we will
unmute you. And Marilyn, I see that
hand. Go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Okay. Why do they say that the two
receptors for nicotine and nasin are
separate and they give them a different
name? Like they say nascin is GP protein
coupled receptors and they say HC2
and GPR 109 and they affect your
metabolite or your cholesterol levels.
But then they say nicotine affects
legand gated ion channels.
So can you explain that? I mean
>> okay. So what's your source?
>> This is from a PubMed article December
2004 and it's titled nicotine
acetylcholine receptors and neuro
psychiatric disord.
>> Okay. So, I would have to see the study,
but there are no nicotine receptors.
They're niacin. So, when they're saying
nicotine, it's just that's it was
labeled.
Okay? And everybody doesn't know that.
The majority of medical people don't
know that.
So, you know, that's that's the only
thing that makes sense.
there are either those that they call
nicotine that are niacin
and then there's other receptors that
don't use that they you know they do
something else in the acetylcholine
receptors and there are a lot of other
receptors okay so it's a it's a to me
it's a situation where
the terminology is everywhere it's
totally pervasive everywhere
and until people start understanding
understanding that that that is a
misleading name. It's not going to
change.
Okay.
>> Hard to understand.
>> Well, I'm just saying
there are no receptors
for nicotine. However, like I just
showed you, those receptors bind to a
certain part of a molecule. And niacin,
nicotinic acid, and nicotine all have
that same they have part of the molecule
together.
But does it say in that research that
they used nicotine
to create the receptor or to work with
the receptor or are they just calling it
nicotine something?
>> They're actually saying nicotine.
They're saying nicotine is acetyl.
>> Yeah. Okay. But that again they say
>> that's the name of the receptor.
>> They are just saying that at the bottom
of the article it says the word
nicotinic is used simply because the
chemical was originally named based on
its molecular resemblance to tobacco
derivatives even though its biological
role as a vitamin B3 is entirely
unrelated to nicotine. But they say at
the bottom.
>> Okay. So they said what I just said.
They said what I just said. They had
named it nicotine even though it's
niacin.
So that's good. That's good. If it's in,
you know, if it's in PubMed like that,
that's good. That's what we want. We
want people to understand it.
Okay.
>> All right.
>> Thanks for the question.
>> All right. Thank you, Marilyn. And uh
Key, go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Hey, Dr. Judy. Nice to see you today.
Um, thank you. I I really appreciate you
taking this subject on because it has
been so outarketed
and I hate to use this word, but it's
been bastardized that people do not
clearly understand the difference in
between these receptors and the labels
that people in the medical field
actually give to these these names. And
if we take a look at pharmaceuticals, if
we take a look at a lot of what's out
there in reference to the alipathic
medical system, we will understand that
virtually everything is mislabeled
and it doesn't go back to the science
that really drives the comprehension and
understanding. So, I just want to tell
you I appreciate you taking that on.
>> Thank you. Um, what that what that leads
back to is if you go back and look way
back in your medical history, it is
believed that they used Latin
for all the terms so that people
couldn't understand them and they had to
go to a doctor or somebody. In other
words, the elite had control of the
information. You had to learn a
different language in order to
understand it. Again, one of my pet
peeves, I took Latin in high school on
purpose because I was planning to be a
veterinarian, which, you know, that
didn't happen, but I ended up doing what
I'm doing now, and I need needed just as
much Latin for this. So, all the
terminology, all the classifications,
again, there's an issue of you can name
things whatever you want to name them.
But then when you look at the Lana
classification system where we take each
if if we discover a new type of frog or
whatever it is, we will name it and fit
it into that classification system. And
it's all Latin. It's all based on Latin.
And I don't know how long Latin's been a
dead language, but I can tell you it's
been a long time. So, you know, another
thing we should kind of start working
towards is, you know, maybe maybe we
should start renaming some of this stuff
when it makes sense. And and that's not
that's a little bit of a separate issue
from the nasin nicotine thing. But it
just I mean like
>> it's part it's part of how what I hear
you saying is it's part of how the
deception the collusion happens on
labels and it becomes a deception and
and not providing the absolute accurate
understanding of what somebody's trying
to say because people will go out and
also do the research on you know Dr.
Google, so to speak, but they can't vet
the information because they really
don't know the science bio and biology
in order to affirm it. And that's what I
find dangerous with just going out and
doing AI searches and then thinking that
you're confident in what you're speaking
about. So, um, again, thank you for
taking it on and it's all over all the
labels in the medical system and people
just have to be able to take the deep
dive to comprehend it differently.
>> Yeah. And you'll notice pharmacist Ben
does he he tells you the word and then
he tells you the where it came from.
>> That's an amazing teaching method. I
love that he does that. I try to do that
myself.
>> Um
so that things make more sense. You know
if you can do that it's from the Latin
for this or that or or that. But anyway
um
>> thank you dear. The good news is that
when I went to school, if you went into
the medical field, you didn't have to do
another language because medicine is it
really is. I did I took some Spanish. I
had to take a little bit of Spanish as
an undergrad. So, I did. But, I mean, I
also found out that people who are good
at the medical stuff like I am are not
that great at language.
So, I mean, I can read and understand
the words and everything, but I can't I
wouldn't be able to speak a language
because it's kind of like two different
parts of your brain, apparently. So, for
for whatever that's worth,
>> thank you.
>> Yep. Thank you.
All right. Thank you, Key. And Rod is
wanting to know, how about for blood
pressure? Would NASCIN be good for blood
pressure?
I I've been reading through all kinds of
things they can do with niacin and yes
it it it does help with blood pressure.
It helps lower cholesterol
but again is that what we really want.
You know the the cholesterol issue is is
again it's one of those things where
there was there was a major deception
and everybody thought cholesterol was
bad and now we know that was wrong. And
so the best way to lower cholesterol is
don't eat sugar. That's don't eat sugar
and starch and all the, you know, stuff
that tastes good.
>> Olive
>> oil, fried foods.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. So, one thing before we go, can
you go over that list of the different
um health conditions that the B3 nascin
was beneficial for?
>> Okay. Sure.
>> Because there's a lot on there that
people don't normally associate
with B3.
>> All right, let's see if I can get back
there. I should be able to. Oh, I know.
I mean, it's
And again, I got to read it off the BL
worse than it was before. I got to get
these curtains changed. We all just
Okay. Um
I mean, these are the chapters in the
book. So each chapter they've talked
about I mean this is serious. This is 50
60 80 years of people studying this
stuff. Okay. Uh you want the list? Okay.
Aging.
Um niacin helps the body prevent genetic
damage
from whatever source. Oxidative stress.
Oh Jesus. Just I'm not
>> Don't worry about it. Don't worry about
it. We can say it well enough.
>> Yeah. Okay. Um
Okay. Arthritis,
children's learning and behavioral
disorders, literally all
the ADHD,
all those kinds of things have been
helped with nasin.
Alcoholism is huge. Um any any
addictions,
Alzheimer's, oh that's kind of a big
one. Anxiety, again, that's part of the
mental stuff. cancer,
cataracts, chalera,
diarrhea, detoxification,
erectile dysfunction,
um let's see, fatigue,
heartnups disease, Huntington's disease,
migraine headaches. NASCIN is involved
in 450 or 500 different chem chemical
reactions.
millions of reactions all the time and
if it if it's not there, you know, if
you're not getting what you need to do
the job.
So all these things like Dr. Wall has
always talked about. Um, they can be
from the bones in your in your skull,
crushing nerves and having all these
happen
and or deficiencies of these other
nutrients.
Multiple sclerosis, nefritis, those
blood vessels going to your kidneys.
Obesity. Well, again,
the all of the carbohydrates, fats,
protein, everything that you're trying
to break down that you eat, the B
vitamins process it, and nasin is
involved in almost all those reactions.
I I did listen to a couple of really
interesting talks at the Equin Science
Society that I'm going to pull up and
give you guys some highlights of because
I had to struggle to keep up with a lady
that was talking about mitochondrial
dysfunction.
She was about to retire, but she's been
at Texas A&M for a long time. I I had
not even met her, but I that's where I
went to school also. But she had a joint
appointment between kinesiology,
human kinesiology and animal science and
she was inter she is interested in
mitochondria.
So very interesting. um the coupling of
the electron transport system and I mean
wow there were several of the talks and
then my friend Brian Nielsen who I
worked with on my project at Texas A&M
on bone where we did the raceh horses
and he he just did his lifetime of
research he did starting with the one he
and I did together at Texas&M and then
he went on and he's been almost 30 years
at Michigan State after he left Texas
A&M him and following along on the
different bone things he's done. So
again, I did a talk on bone and now I
can expand it to the things because he's
been researching it this whole time
while I've been creating horse feeds and
stuff like that. So anyway, there's it
it's just always fun for me to find new
stuff. But post-traumatic stress
disorder, Rainayod's disease, skin
conditions, trigeminal neuralgia, and
then they have the whole thing about
COVID.
Um, yeah, these others, the index,
I don't know if if if people are really
interested in this, this book is a gold
mine. And I'm afraid that,
you know, they might not if people don't
buy it, they might not be.
>> Will you Will you hold that up? I want
them to not just see the cover, but to
see how much research you really do into
something.
>> Oh,
yeah.
>> Here's what happens. I look it up and I
put a little marker on there where I
looked it up and pretty soon it's
useless because everything's marked.
>> It doesn't matter anymore. But
>> it's not useless. I've been I've been
watching or I've been I've been
following a person who is doing what he
calls an analog system.
And there's a couple of really good
reasons for that. But what he says is we
need to write when we read, we need to
write our thoughts. And you can't use a
computer.
And I just found a study about children
saying
they they you know check chemicals in
the brain
and when the when a child writes
you have to very carefully write
and all these things in the brain are
lighting up as the child writes. But
when you put them on a keyboard nothing
because each keystroke is the same. And
so when they stopped teaching kids to
write and they started putting them on
keyboards, they're losing all kinds of
potential brain function. And it's the
same concept, this analog. So you set
your system up, you read your books, you
know, you have your resources stuff, but
when I read,
>> I put little post-it notes or I write in
the margins. I'll go no or something.
But you write all that up. Those are
your legitimate thoughts. If you put
them on a computer, it doesn't come out
the same. Right? So, what that means is
keeping all your stuff, actually writing
your thoughts, and you're getting your
input, your human brain, you know, how
you've analyzed everything, your input,
and it's completely separate. And he he
says it's just if people keep putting
everything into computers,
we're going to lose all of that.
You know, it's the same thing with a
digital book.
I'll read them if I have to,
>> but I got to have some place to write
about it, you know, to what I'm going to
do with it. So anyway, that was
>> a bit of a diversion, but
>> huge things for kids
that have recently Well, we know we know
kids that can't see the mother's face,
kids that can't touch people, kids that
are afraid of the air, kids, you know,
all these things are big. So
>> yeah. Wow. I think that could be a whole
another show, Dr. Judy. Well, I I think
an update on kids needs to come. Um, and
I also did that I did a huge like a
six-day conference on mental health
>> and I haven't had a chance to summarize
most of that and talk about it either.
So, there's so much. It's just a
question of what's more important. What
I wanted to do, what I was originally
going to do today was the one, the
epigenetics one about my research
because it's a mystery. It's like things
were happening. These horses had this
thing happening to them for years and
nobody knew what was happening. Well
then when they developed the genetic
tests right at that time they started
developing the genetic tests so they
knew what it was and it happened right
when I was looking for a project. So
it's it's really a mystery and I I will
do that. Um,
so it's an epigenetic mystery really.
But the fun thing about it is, you know,
you when that happens and you happen I
happen to be at a place where we had
horses that had it and didn't have it
and we could do it otherwise I couldn't
have done it. But it ended up being like
the the only and the main
research on how to feed those horses for
the whole world. And I had a laugh
because when Brian was talking the other
day, he was talking about, you know,
well, we just do one little step at a
time in the bone thing, he was talking
about, does being in a stall affect a
horse's bone development? And people
didn't think it did. Guess what? It
does. And he made this comment, well, we
can only do one step at a time. But I
was thinking, except in my case where I
happened to be able to totally figure it
out how to feed them. There wasn't a
whole lot more you had to figure out. So
that was it was just I was like just
lucky so lucky to end up in that thing.
But I think it's more fun to look at it
like you know like a mystery that you're
trying to solve.
>> So that's what we're doing all of us
people you know when we're when someone
comes us comes to us with problems and
symptoms and issues and that's what Dr.
Wik did and that's what we're all doing
is well what what can we do for that
person? So that's why we need to know
about them, you know, we need to know a
certain amount about them or the animal
or whatever. So
>> and it's not one sizefits-all.
>> No.
>> So absolutely
>> because especially when the the
environment around them can be totally
different.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, Dr. Judy, thank you so much for
coming on today and sharing sharing
about niacin and how even nicotinomide
or niconic
nicotinic acid
um is nascin. Yeah, I if if you think
about it and of course I like I said I
think nasin has gotten a bum wrap the
whole time. That's what's going to come
out happening. It's not the It's not the
nasin and the tobacco. It's the
chemicals they put in that made
everybody sick. That's a whole another,
you know, deal. But
did do do you remember when the whole
first thing came out and they figured
all the smokers were going to have a
really bad outcome because it was a lung
problem and they were smokers
and the opposite happened.
>> Yeah. So even though all the chemicals
were there, probably
that nicotine was being changed, it was
either blocking the problem, blocking
the venom or was being changed to
niacin,
but they were not the ones that got
really sick. So that's kind of a clue.
Something was weird, too. So
yeah, definitely something weird. Well,
thank you. Thank you. Thank you for for
coming on and I know that you are a huge
Dr. Wallik follower and today is his
birthday.
>> Oh, happy birthday Dr.
>> Wall 87.
All right. 87
>> 87. Yeah.
>> 87 years old today. So huge shout out to
Dr. Joel Wallik. And
>> happy happy birthday. Um, we miss having
you on the show and I but I know that
you're enjoying retirement and getting
to know your family, uh, spending more
time with them. So, if I could get our
co-hosts up on the screen with us, that
would be absolutely fantastic as I'm so
thankful that I do not have to do the
show all by myself with my guest. um
they're keeping an eye on other things
and including the technical side of it
and the ongoing part and uh
transcription. Come on Marilyn, there
you are. All right. Well, today we have
with us um Sherry who's part of the tech
crew. Sherry and Mary and Ruth Allen
each part of the tech crew who are here
with us today. So thankful for each of
them as they are um keeping an eye on
the stream making sure that there's
audio there's if there's questions
they're bringing those questions in.
Coach Rod is helping to bring in some
questions as well and Ruth Ellen being
my executive production manager and uh
also taking the Zoom putting that
graphics with it pushing it out. So that
is what you are seeing if you're out on
Zoom or Rumble or X or Instagram or any
of or Facebook any of the different
platforms. Um make sure that you are
subscribed, like us and most importantly
share us with people that you know and
love. And we also have Albert joining us
from
far far far away in South Africa. Thank
you so much, Albert, as he is our
gatekeeper.
And I see that we do have one more hand
up. Let's see if we can get a question
real quick.
And is it Aan? Ian, are you
>> um can you just remind me if you like um
if you go on the YouTube another live
session, can you send me the Zoom
meeting link?
Um, the Zoom meeting link is exactly how
you got here.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Um, yeah. So, if you're here in the
Zoom, then you've got like if you have
another like a Zoom meeting about this
because I was interested. I was planning
on YouTube about this advertisement.
Can you send me another Zoom meeting?
just is very suitable for me to join. I
like that.
>> Um, so we are here Wednesdays,
Thursdays, and Fridays from 12 to 1:00
p.m. Pacific, 1 to 2 Mountain, 2 to 3
Central. Not quite sure where you're
located. Um, but I think I got that
wrong. 12 to 1 Pacific or Yeah. 1 to 2
Mountain, 2 to 3 Central, 3 to 4 Eastern
time. Um, and we do have a new guest
each and every day. So, make sure that
you go to dailywithdoc.com,
sign up for our email list so that you
get a notification of who we have on
with us that day. And you can also, if
you're subscribed to one of the channels
that we go live on, when we're starting
to go live, you will get notification
that we are live and you can watch us
either live or after the fact.
on any of the different platforms. Just
do a search for daily with Doc and Becca
and it will come up with all of the
different areas that or platforms that
we do broadcast on. So even the ones
we're not live on, there's many many
others that we load everything up to so
that people can watch it at their
leisure and watch it or listen to it
once or many times. So, thank you again
everybody for being here with us. Thank
you for our live audience and our
questions that came in from the live
audience. And again, Dr. Judy Reynolds,
you are just such a wealth of
information. And thank you for that
tidbit on writing because I totally
understand how when I write something, I
remember it so much better than when I
tape it.
That's
>> Yes.
hands down.
>> Hands down. Where it's easier to find
when I type it, but it's not easier to
remember.
>> So, yeah.
>> Thank you everybody once again. My name
is Becca Dukes. As a certified
naturopathic practitioner, a certified
holistic health coach, and the director
of student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health, it is my honor and
privilege to provide this resource of
learning to you and the world. If you'd
like more information about becoming a
certified holistic health coach, go to
coach.dwithdoc.com.
Again, that's coach
dailywithdoc.com.
But if you are referred to this program
by somebody specific, get back with
them, ask if they're a certified
holistic health coach and how they can
join you in the coaching program as
well.
If you have um questions that you're not
and you're not already working with
somebody and you want to speak with a
certified holistic health coach, call
3377.
Again, 855-9493377.
Well, for tomorrow we have pharmacist
Ben Fix.
Can somebody please stop the uh chat?
Um, join us. We'll talk to you later.
Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford postdo
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases.